Um, the next question is, and and I
guess also just to clarify, the I guess
the question was asking if we keep the
Sabbath, does that guarantee that we're
going to heaven?
Submission to Christ. Stay Let's go to
John 15. Let's see something that's
very, very critical when it comes to our
relationship with Christ. John 15 from
verse 4.
Abide in me, and I in you.
As the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine, no
more can ye except ye abide in me. Verse
5. I am the vine, you are the branches.
He that abideth in me and I in him, the
same bringeth forth much fruit, for
without me you can do nothing. Let's go
to verse 7. If ye abide in me and my
words abide in you, ye shall ask what
you will, and it shall be done unto you.
Verse 9. As the Father hath loved me, so
have I loved you. Continue ye in my
love. The word continue means abide.
Verse 10. If ye keep my commandments, ye
shall abide in my love, even as I have
kept my Father's commandments and abide
in his love. From verses 1 to 10 or 11,
we have abide about 10 times.
Jesus says in Matthew 24:14, I believe
it is, he that endures to the end of
verse 13, the same shall be saved.
There must be a staying in Christ, you
see. A staying Faith and Works, page
100, paragraph 1. God requires the
entire surrender of the heart in order
for justification to take place. And in
order for men to retain justification,
there must be continual obedience
through active living faith that works
by love and purifies the soul. And so
there's the coming to Christ, and
there's the staying in Christ.
A lot of people come to Christ and they
think that's it. Once saved, always
saved. No, no, no. There must be
faithful obedience through the power of
Christ. And we must love Christ more
than we love our own lives. And so the
key is total surrender. Our High
Calling, page 215, paragraph 2, I
believe it is. Ellen White writes,
"Genuine conversion is needed not once
in years, but daily."
This is the life that we must live. And
the power to live that Christ is the
power That life is the power of Christ.
Amen. Thank you very much, Elder Skeete.
Mhm. We're getting so many questions
that are coming in. Someone has asked,
I I'm I'm Someone has asked So, we spoke
about the nature walk. Someone has
asked, is it okay um, to go swimming or
go on the beach on Sabbath?
Now, you see
I've heard that before. You know, they
also say go fishing. What is your motive
for that? You see, when in doubt, don't
do it.
When in doubt, don't do it.
Why are you going swimming if there's a
question mark about that activity?
Because very often we say we're doing
things for God, but we're really doing
them for ourselves. Our underlying
motive is self-gratification. When
there's a question mark about an
activity, it's best to avoid it, whether
it's swimming, fishing, or you know,
jumping out of an airplane, whatever it
may be. And people try to put it under
the heading of I am in nature. Well, I'm
in nature right now sitting in this room
in my house. If I'm in a bus, I'm in
nature because I'm on the earth. Are you
following me? And so we must be careful.
What is the motive? And very often we
don't know our true motives.
Swimming
I would not classify as the same thing
as a nature walk. But I'm not God.
But the person who asked that, or any
person of a similar mind, must ask
himself or herself, "What is my real
motive? Am I pursuing my joy, or am I
trying to learn a little more about God
by observing the tree and the animals
and the sky and the seas?"
Amen. Amen.